un plan indépendant pour créer un cadre
juridique social et fiscal plus simple
et plus protecteur pour les trois
millions d' indépendants en france c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le président de la
république emmanuel macron jeudi matin à
l'issue de cette annonce bruno le maire
et alain griset se sont rendus à saint
germain en laye pour rencontrer des
professionnels indépendants touchés par
la crise sanitaire
c'est pas parce qu'on est indépendant
qu'on doit pas être protégé dans son
activité économique donc les mesures qui
ont été annoncées sur l'assurance
chômage sur les reprises sur la saisie
du patrimoine personnel ce sont des
protections que nous apportons aux
indépendants il est venu non pas en
distance yale non pas en vidéo mais voir
comment les choses se passent donc on
est ravis qu'il soit là qu'ils se
rendent compte par lui-même du
redémarrage de l'économie et de la
relance favoriser la transmission de
l'entreprise protéger le patrimoine
personnel ou encore faciliter l'accès à
l'assurance chômage les vingt mesures du
plan ont été détaillées aux
entrepreneurs présents je pense qu'il ya
un travail de plus long terme que nous
avons voulu faire avec le président de
la république qui était annoncé ce matin
pour soutenir les indépendants dans les
années qui viennent et régler un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'ils restaient
les difficultés indépendante important
pour tous les indépendants la difficulté
sur le recrutement difficultés parce
qu'il ya encore des choses qui sont trop
complexes des formulaires entre complexe
l'occasion aussi d'aller à la rencontre
des commerçants et artisans de la ville
qui comporte plus de 800 commerces pour
expliquer concrètement le plan aux plus
concernés joe vous transmettrez votre
affaire vous aurez une défiscalisation
qui est plus élevé que ce qui existait
auparavant et votre repreneur plus dur
c'est de trouver de repreneur dans le
service le repreneur est pour lui dire
qu'il faut va pouvoir amortir son fonds
de commerce
sur ses recettes dans les années à venir
toutes les mesures annoncées seront
applicables dès janvier 2022 selon
l'exécutif